so a botnet is different than isolated
pieces of malware in the fact that a
botnet is a collection of infected
machines which are coordinated through
command and control by a central server
which is called the command and control
server or the CNC server so the power of
botnets is basically in the amount of
distributed computation and storage
power that is available to a CNC server
it's short for robot is it then I'm
guessing yeah so the body is basically
for machines that can operate in an
automated fashion which refers to the
robot the thing that we mentioned ok and
a botnet is a collection of these that
somebody is using for nefarious purposes
that will not be right or does it have
to be yeah usually it is for nefarious
purposes so the main two strengths of a
botnet from the point of view of a bad
guy is one that there is there are like
words on the order of hundreds and
thousands of machine so there is a lot
of distributed computing and storage
power available there and the other one
is a certain delegation of
responsibility or deniability which the
infrastructure affords to the person who
runs the botnet in terms of that the
person conducts all these nefarious
activities from the platform of the bots
and not just directly usually people are
not aware and basically stealth and
botnets usually go hand-in-hand because
from the point of view of a C&C server
it wants to ensure that the ports remain
infected and available and stay that way
for the longest period of time possible
so if the user is aware that you know it
has been infected then you typically
they would probably reinstall the
operating system or take other measures
to clean the machine which doesn't work
in the favor of the botnet controller
I'm assuming this starts from people
opening dodgy emails or something is
that the sort of thing that starts this
off for innocent user sitting there
using their computer so every botnet has
a propagation mechanism and nothing is
stopping it from using multiple
propagation vectors so for example a
partner it can spread yourself in a
passive ways or inactive ways so active
ways usually involve
little or no user intervention basically
no user intervention in the sense that
if a machine has been infected then the
bot binary has inherent mechanisms to
find other hosts on the internet to
infect for example by scanning for hosts
that have known vulnerabilities that can
be exploited and then there are passive
mechanisms that you that require some
degree of user intervention for example
drive-by downloads which are websites
that have say some active content like
JavaScript or ActiveX controls so just a
user when he or she visits the website
they the installation of the malware
takes place in an automated fashion so
just because they visited that website
the website might be doing something
that they think oh look flash active
this that or the other in fancy graphics
but in the background it could be doing
something much more serious yeah and
there are other passive ways also I mean
social engineering is a very powerful
way of spreading malware in general
especially portlets which involves some
kind of human interaction to convince a
user to take steps that they would
otherwise do not not do for example a
pop-up thing that pops up and says you
have won a lottery click on this link to
claim the money and you click on the
link and it initiates the download of
the malware to your machine and then we
also have propagation mechanisms like
like like media for example USB sticks
which is potentially very powerful
because it allows the infection to
spread to private networks which are
otherwise inaccessible over the Internet
I mean usually the malicious binary is
in the form of an executable so it just
starts running right like it doesn't
need you to double-click it where does
the command machine come in you know is
that some being controlled by summer or
is that itself about so I think we can
make use of some diagrams here yeah yeah
absolutely
okay so here's the CNC server here and
here is the user the innocent user say
that through whatever propagation vector
either through clicking on some bad
links or through some infected media to
use
our installs the malicious software
which is associated with the botnet
usually it's called the bots finery
binary means the executable code which
can be directly run by the Machine
without the need to be compiled by
installing the bot binary the user has
got the infection but it is not formally
part of the botnet now it needs to find
some way to locate the CNC server to be
able to exchange messages with it so it
needs some rallying mechanism now the
running mechanism can take place in the
form of an IP address that is the IP
address can be hard-coded into the bot
binary or the user can obtain a seed
list of IP addresses which would be
basically IP addresses of some other
hosts which know how to locate the CNC
server so basically like a stepping
stone between the CNC server and the
user to locate the CNC server apart from
IP address the user could also
potentially use some domain name related
to the CNC server and the domain name
could likewise be hard-coded into the
bot binary or the user can make use of
some algorithm which is known to the
user and to the CNC server to generate
predictable domain names which are then
associated with the CNC server either
way once the user finds out how to
communicate with the CNC server it
connects to it now the user is formally
part of the botnet and it has kind of
registered itself with the botnet so
typically if the CNC server wants the
bots to carry out certain nefarious
activities on its behalf it is able to
access that particular bot now the
purposes for which these BOTS can be
used are different for example the bots
can be used for the purpose of
information gathering which involves
sensitive information like passwords
credit card information or information
which is not of a financial nature but
still valuable for example intellectual
property the other purpose for which the
botnet can use its pots is for
distributed computing for example
distributed password cracking getting
bots to solve CAPTCHAs basically
anything that requires proof of work and
is infeasible for for BOTS for the bot
master the person who controls the
botnet to carry out individually it can
distribute it across
recruited BOTS and get them to do it on
its behalf and is this the CNC machine
is obviously under the control of the
whoever the bot master is yeah is that
they're usually their own computer or is
that again remote from them so is there
what I was wondering if there was a way
of tracing them yes so it would be very
naive of a bot master to directly use
its own machine for the CNC purposes and
usually how it evades detection is to
incorporate several stepping stones
between itself and the Machine and for
example it could login to that machinery
access that machine using the Tor
network so that way it is using that
machine anonymously and remove all
traces of its identity and basically be
untraceable
how many botnets are actually
approaching on the Internet at the
moment is it is the regular can anyone
hazard a guess at those numbers or it's
hard to say because I mean how can you
count the number of parts that are
controlled right like if it's a
centralized botnet and there is say one
or like a limited number of CNC servers
in one specific case they looked at all
the incoming connections to the CNC
server which kind of helped them
estimate the footprint of the botnet
which is the number of parts that formed
part of the botnet but who knows if
there are other CNC servers related to
the same botnet because you know like
looking from the vantage point of one
CNC server would afford you visibility
into only its own footprint so there
have been academic studies on estimates
of botnet footprints but one cannot
really be completely accurate about that
is there any way that that kind of
technology can be used for good or is it
always for various reasons well it's
kind of being used for the good in the
context of censorship resistant systems
where good users are trying to access
some content which has been banned in
their country using more or less the
same evasive measures which are used by
port nets or malware to evade security
people so it's the same model turned
upside down
by subtracting these frames from each
other we can virtually shroud the
influence of daylight so we can even
eliminate cast shadows which would
because